welcome to this video playing tactic was
Zoltan made VG from Hungary we usually
have some kind of double fianchetto can
i let's transpose to the Queen's engine
I'm not really any any sort of expert
but I don't want to double field shadow
again it's kind of boring so what about
this now they three Queens Indian oh
that line no I don't know that at all I
think white can do this it's a bit on
the conservative side but not bad with
Bishop d3 coming just trying to develop
it possibly gain some space whoa really
isn't that pretty weakening hmm
hmm
okay this is the case where this is a
quiz just that was just bad i'm
practically speaking I should just play
the move I take any way at the end and I
could have done so much much quicker
because I don't believe that this is an
entirely healthy structure let's see you
just f3 or yeah okay let's just go after
am I think that at the end i will get
any form and this is not very
comfortable yeah he arrives maybe one
night f6 that could also be a tribe
Queen f4 is an interesting move here
pinning him and going for Queen to c6
let's do that it's an interesting idea
not really well thought out but it feels
like worth trying c6 is pretty weak
after all yeah so let's let's go on that
journey he has rook f6 I Scotty 5 as a
as an idea that's a bit awkward didn't
really take that into account hmm ok
well I have the check so it's not a not
very pressing threat can I i can go 95
and just try to take that is that really
i'd really on i also have a form
intending you form may be actually you
525 check that should be good let's do
that I'm not really developed to say
this makes the whole operation look a
bit risky
but I mean his position has some
drawbacks Bishop g5 is also a threat now
and she has some some trouble keeping
its material together like Bishop g5
roop 26 but should be 737 three takes
eight oops this kind of thing it's also
in ne5 a pawn to e5 can be annoying as
well okay just moves the rook yeah well
here I can castle or I can take on f5
and then Queen d5 chick think II
castling cannot really be bad I have to
do that anyway I guess maybe I could
have taken and just 25 25 or so much not
sure
never that I mean what exactly is a
smooth okay now again I can take 25
Queen f5 and grab that part is that
something else or better like a Wookiee
one or so I mean what does he have not
be eight maybe okay I'm taking it's a
porn at least check unfortunately I
don't seem to have anything great yeah
so I'm grabbing two e-form probably a
tree form yeah for possible Bishop g5
and 19 5s and so on this one yeah he
prevents this to specially for maybe
well Bishop over to g3 on now that that
looks fine 95 is also a pretty strong
continuation if I can get this in
centralizing okay don't night each floor
maybe but ok I can I can just cover him
come on just play normal rules no need
for anything fancy one minute 47 ok
I wonder it's night age for how strong
that is actually it's not bad but is it
necessary or is there something better
it feels it feels pretty forcing
actually let's do that not sure ideas
basis you take on f6 look everyone i'd
have this rook takes f8 threat but i
could have played like a 45 just
continuing with the squeeze difficult to
say what what was better than
yes giving this pawn yeah 25 I cannot
play so i have to take with the pawn
yeah no alternative there this was one
reason why i was thinking that maybe
taking weight taking not taking a g5
could be an idea but now okay for one
right that shouldn't be so bad if i take
a fade route chicks 96 check 2g 8g 93 f
8 it's pretty strong but what what
exactly is this next movement continued
a little bit 9 f 5 is also not bad at
all and d 6 oh man resigned you for yeah
yeah I could have this sir sorry okay I
just have I just have 97 so I cannot
draw maybe I have to go on back here I
have this now hmm jam that i don't i
don't really believe that f5 is this is
a great idea I'm sorry I mean d5 here I
sort of remember a game of chronic
kramnik with white I think against Rafa
our guard isn't that that game or
something like that I'm really not not
sure about it but that looks pretty
miserable for black at least it looks
better for wild qui qui n'a for i'm not
sure but i think it's a good idea and be
looking at the c6 square is this I am
computer has just unfazed does this
because if I grab
I'm jabbing myself very nice so I have
to do something else then if I go here
it comes up with the assistance by
playing against the computer so awful
yeah and all of a sudden my bad
development is blowing up in my face and
he in this and black wins according to
the computer you know where I
development is really bad okay you for
happened Luke g6 that the computer wants
to go rook c8 and says equal hmm
interesting interesting I felt pretty
optimistic here but he's got tonight be
eight now so if i do this he will go
nite be eight and this is no good if I
go if I hear 98 bad group g6 castle see
guys got c5 and let's definitely play
over black again I'm not well developed
so rook c8 and maybe this is what I have
to do then I mean if I castle again that
this move and all of a sudden my
position is shaky huh yeah so that clean
to c6 venture wasn't that brilliant or
maybe I should avoid he fired the eform
only this machine seems to lead to
trouble I just cancelled this also felt
interesting chat is king back and grab
but now he can't in here ok so I have to
cancel anyway and the rook is not that
well placed on g6 this is probably the
real problem went here
and now I'm just graduated yeah that's
the best line also he doesn't really
have a great coordination sister this is
one issue who's this and now be three
covering c4 yeah I wasn't sure nie Dage
forward it's the engine roof so it was
the most forceful I wasn't sure because
it can easily play like d 594 stuff like
that just continuing to improve but I
mean I just felt that it is it is the
time is right for decisive measures and
it is supported by the computer she
takes here and this is this here light
at 5i I went went here yeah I could have
done that immediately but what is
happening here could we offer you 50 K
cannot defend yourself yeah now the end
is near 97 or queen g4 it's also going
to be pretty fatal I think there's a
game chronic with white against for gan
yong i think in the mid-90s so like
1994-1995 we had something very very
similar happened maybe i should look
that up just a moment yeah I found that
game and it is indeed somewhat similar
please ignore the ratings of course yeah
at the time Kramnik was not an IM or
whatever so 1995 it keeps the I I meant
the ratings from the Blitz game um yeah
it was indeed somewhat similar g5 it's
the same thing and now takes takes takes
f3 so I remembered somehow I remembered
this stuff and here a ghanaian went
Bishop d6 like a tactical try added
defense after the capture Queen takes f3
is given in the annotations by the way
not night takes what I did
and magana played Bishop t6 check and
then Queen a form c6 and yeah the key
movie is this that was a very strong
move takes 94 with the tempo and now
white got fantastic activity on the long
diagonal was a very powerful display
typical of chrome Nick in the 90s
especially in those tournaments when he
when you faced strong opposition but not
the very elite opposition then he was
usually destroying people like that here
okay well thanks for watching